[Musique]
il n'y a qu'une seule manière d'éviter
la pénurie de place dans nos hôpitaux et
dont d'éviter d'éventuels drame restent
pour au maximum chez nous et respectons
les lignes de conduite pas de bise ayant
des distances raisonnables entre nous
tous on donne au coude
protégeons nos aînés et aussi nos jeunes
parce que nous sommes tous concernés
c'est vrai nous ne sauverons sans doute
pas tout le monde mais peut-être au
moins une vie et c'est en respecte rien
suivant les consignes que nous y
arriverons là vont nos mains sans
modération on va s'en sortir sans sortir
en suspens tout jouer et pivi oui cela
parce qu'il parte a joué dix personnes
m